so redo of healer
i'm not gonna lie it hasn't been a great
watching experience
the things i've seen it's uh
i mean it's really not that bad i'm kind
of joking but that might only be because
i've watched my fair share of degenerate
anime and you know the uh sexual abuse
i guess is a nicer euphemism is
something i've seen before
it's nothing new really for a degenerate
like me
and if you haven't heard of redo of
healer or we're thinking oh i've seen a
bunch of buzz about that one should i
check it out
no no no no you should not
because that's why i'm here to save you
the visual and auditory torment of
watching this show
and give my take on it instead and yeah
i'm talking bad about it right now but
it's honestly just a really bad anime
that
let's be real it's just a hentai
and i even made a funny little outro
that i edited just for you guys that you
won't want to miss at the end of the
video
so enjoy the rest and enjoy my take on
redo of healer
so where do i even begin the plot the
plot right
so basically this guy named kearu has
this healing power
which isn't just you know healing
injuries but is basically
anything he wants it to be he's grossly
overpowered for
no reason really other than to move the
plot forward and let him dominate anyone
he wants
in the fantasy world this story takes
place in kr becomes a hero once he
becomes an adult
it seems like this is a very rare
occurrence and it's an honor to become a
hero
you're branded on your hand and you get
like powers there's a gun hero a sword
hero and kyaru is the healing
hero he gets taken by flair
or judare is how he says it i'll just
say flair it's easier
the princess of the big ol powerful
kingdom to be her partner
to defeat the demon king and he's the
squad healer
he's like that one guy in the party that
can't play dps and so he's hard stuck in
silver as like a bottom tier healer
if you play video games i don't but
chaora's healing power ends up being
really overpowered and he can cure
well anything full arms things that
normally can't be helped
he can do it however comma whenever he
uses his power to heal someone he
basically gets all of their memories
including their traumas which
essentially breaks his mind every time
he has to heal someone
and bear the burden of their pain but
there's another caveat as well
to make him even more overpowered he can
take the abilities of anyone he heals
and use it as his own
and after he heals his first person he
realizes like
damn i don't want to do this anymore it
sucks having to bear these people's pain
but flair the nice cute little princess
girl ends up being a super mean
little princess girl and forces kearu to
keep doing it
she chains him up and force feeds him
drugs to make him into an addict or
slave to do her bidding
on top of forcing him to bear these
people's pain chain him up
force drugs on him the list does go on
she lets other heroes sexually abuse him
as well
i would prefer not to you know use the r
word in my videos
sorry because his bodily fluids if you
know what i mean
if ingested or taken into your body
through
other holes boosts your powers this
isn't really explained all too well
but basically to put it simply sex with
kyaru
equals stronger and more healing and so
he's sexually abused and tormented
every single day and night and just
horribly tortured
you feel bad for him and then one day as
the squad consisting of him
bullet this guy who's like in love with
him or something and takes advantage of
him all the time
flair who we all know and love of course
and this other blonde girl who's in love
with flair and ends up beating the crap
out of kyaru because of that
face off against the demon king but op
god ke aru with all his cool powers that
he's taken
make him actually stronger than the
demon king and beats them and takes the
sorcerer's stone which
they have for some reason which is just
like a really overpowered magical tool
like it is in every story
and he uses it to amplify his healing
magic and literally turn back time
to before all of this so he can take
revenge on flair and the rest of the
people who hurt him
hence redo of healer he's just redoing
about the whole story
and so we go all the way back to the
beginning and kr gets like this really
strong eyeball from this lake fairy
that gives him back his memory because
he lost that when he went back in time
or turned back time or whatever
and so he replays everything except this
time before he goes with flare to the
kingdom he eats like a bunch of
mushrooms that make him resistant to
drugs so she can't make him into an
addict
and you know with the knowledge of
everything that happens how she's gonna
act
he goes with her has sex with a bunch of
people to get their powers
and get strong again and after a couple
months once the king leaves town he
pounces
and this is the scene that has made the
show notorious the one you see in
everyone's thumbnails right now
it's his revenge on flair i think what's
so bad or notorious about the scene is
that the show really doesn't hold back
at all we see him break all of her
fingers and then once she's had enough
he heals them and starts over again
and once she can't handle that he uh has
his way with her
big time and it's uh it's pretty
disturbing to see
i mean i guess she did let like dozens
of people do that to him
so he isn't the bad guy i mean that's
the reason why this show isn't
completely terrible
like he's doing it for revenge it's been
done to him before
but it's just really really [ __ ] up
he uses like healing corruption magic i
guess that's a thing
to render her legs useless as he does it
and then afterwards uses another like
healing brainwashing magic to erase her
memories of who she is
the show uses healing really lightly as
a term
and you basically don't have to know how
anything works except that he's
overpowered and kyaru can basically do
anything he wants to
and then once he's had his way with her
spends the night together he takes her
with him as he continues on his journey
to take revenge on
everyone else like that dude bullet and
the blonde i mentioned earlier
i really just can't remember her name
does anyone know it
so is the show good no
is the show pretty disturbing yeah
is it entertaining eh
look if you haven't watched a lot of bad
anime or you know degenerate anime
you probably shouldn't watch the show
ease your way into it you know
get some boku no pico some high school
dxd in your system first
like there's so much other stuff you can
watch this season
have a taste of horry mia a wholesome
anime or one of the like million sequels
out right now
just you know save yourself the hour and
a half that's come out of the show so
far
i'll watch the rest and keep you guys
updated so uh
keep yourself pure and so here's that
little bit i was talking about at the
beginning of the video i hope you guys
enjoy it
[Music]
wait wait no i want to redo
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video and that little bit
make sure to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
[Music]
you